it was literally no other race of people
that have that many assumptions tied to
a guest on 15 years ago natural hair out
afro hair out was seen as unprofessional
and unkempt and even now kids in school
are still fighting to have the right to
wear their hair in its natural state to
school because to some teachers it's
seen as unkempt or undone which is
distracting who's at first I always felt
like I wasn't allowed to express myself
and wear my hair the way I wanted it
even at school I wasn't allowed like
long
swishy braids would be thin or anything
like that when I was going to school I
used to hate my mum footing my hair cuz
like I felt like I know like a spider I
usually say like I've got like eight
legs coming out and my mum used to be
like it's the easiest thing that she
knew how it was generation and now I
kind of feel bad that like I never
learned how to do it I do feel like
within the community there may be the
natural hair people and the people that
wear weave and sometimes natural hair
people feel like they if you wear weaves
you hate yourself
they were pressure within that community
to always have these curls doing do this
and you know the fur just to be this
size and the collar to be amazing it's
like who's good the time because I'm so
mean
I just find with my experience
Hair Stylist might be more used to
dealing with European hair I mean I do
wear wigs which is kind of like a
costume man I usually have like an afro
yeah wigs has become even it's like
almost the rows of reversing now because
it's like Europeans tend to use it more
through and that was me through watching
that Game of Thrones and like programs
and understand how much they use as well
like more than probably we need
I know a lot of black people especially
black women who rocked the whole really
Afrocentric natural hair yeah they would
look at what we've got a now to be like
you don't love yourself I remember the
first time I got my hair cut is because
it was a it's because it was damaged
from a relaxer all right and when I
remember like crying so much and being
like oh I look like a boy this that and
the other like I'm so attracted with
short hair and because I've grown into
it I think now it'd be weird to to go
back the other way yeah I damage my hair
so much as well I've said too much
oh my god I damage it so much to the
point where I like it was kind of like
translucent here and so it's just like
let's kind of I used to have my hair and
like a big afro with a bit of I'll cause
follicular assistance and I want my hair
like that for a year and I'd never got
into so many arguments with strangers
because well everybody wanted to touch
it just that sense of entitlement and
having that ownership over somebody's
closet you just without a second thought
and and people that in other ways in
many other ways are often like very
reserved this is where you've got
strength to touch my head this is where
you're flexing and that's what's crazy
to me I would never go up and touch a
stranger like never liked any part of
them
our hair is just so politicized and in a
way that just makes no sense I think
black hair still is is political and if
it if it wasn't you wouldn't have laws
coming up just being written into
legislation like this this year making
it like illegal to discriminate against
black people for being so audacious as
to leave their hair in the way that it
naturally naturally grows from their
head for me it's not just black hair
that's political I feel like black
bodies are political
I feel like hair will be political as
long as black women are denounced and
more commented on just because of the
hair that they choose
until all children can go to school with
braids over to work with dreads and feel
like they can go in their natural hair
hair black woman's head will be
political which is such a shame
everything we do is always gonna be seen
as political yeah and it is innately
political as well right but sometimes it
literally is just cut my hair off it's
easy to say manage time in the morning
no I definitely mine was like the
mixture of that and the mixture of like
they're like oh the rebel fighting
I'm still a jeju-do with a big on with a
big off with straight hair with a for
her however it is I'm still the same
person and it kind of feels like can I
just be me first before I'm actually a
representation of black women
[Music]